neil put out an album called the barn
and i guess the idea was to not only
show you recording the album which i
love i like this idea of musicians
pulling the curtain back
and showing you the recording process
and it's a very well shot film i was
shocked daryl hannah your wife she shot
the whole thing on her ipad she has a
fascination
with you urinating there's a move you do
when you're recording the album now it's
twice in the film you walk outside
and you urinate and she has the camera
focused on you from the back we don't
see your penis but we see you from
behind urinating when she showed you
this film that she was doing did you say
to her honey what what is this howard
i look at it and i and i i imagine
what would the album have been like if i
hadn't urinated
yeah for i went for a week and didn't
ever urinate that would not be a good
album i think i would be in bad shape
you know so i think she saved my ass i
believe you have a very large penis and
i'll tell you why because you're not
ashamed to urinate on camera you know
like you didn't you know you're an
audience
his wife's there i don't let my wife see
me pee god forbid she sees what that
looks like but well you know it's just
we don't want to get people to get
excited and see this movie for that
because
[Laughter]
no it's all back shots i'm standing in a
field what's he doing he's standing
there oh
but there is a liberation in it isn't it
there's something beautiful about peeing
on the land uh i find it
i think it's real
i keep it real i know that musicians are
very particular about this sound and you
are especially to use this barn as a
recording studio seems like something
you would be bothered by because all of
the outside noise and everything is
coming in there's no soundproofing
whatsoever well the outside noise is all
great
that's one thing and there's the the
barn is
it was built in 1860 or 1870 and we
restored it just last year most
musicians today they record in studios
and they got all these things to make it
sound good we didn't have any of that
because we don't need it because we have
logs on top of logs with round surfaces
there is no reflection there's no
standing waves we record what we do
we don't record what we think we're
doing
or what we think we want to just sound
like we record what we did because that
was it and we try to record the first
time we do it because that's what people
deserve to hear it the original is still
the greatest i mean the first is the
best the cherry you know what can you do
that's the way it's been for a long time
so that's the way i like to record and
the horse is totally tuned into that